Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est dimanche
C'est donc le jour des explications !
Et pour la première fois depuis le 1er janvier,
Je ne suis pas tout seul pour une explication
Je suis avec Leonard !
Leonard, si vous ne connaissez pas, il fait des vidéos funs
Je regarde, je me marre,
et  je ne me pose pas de question, c'est le concept de la chaine
- Ok, donc je prend ça comme un compliment
mais biensûr !
Je vais donc vous expliquer un tour pour que vous puissiez à votre tour
bluffer les gens dès cet après-midi, dès ce soir, dès demain,  dès cette semaine
Mais vous m'avez souvent demander dans les commentaires
si je pouvais faire le tour à quelqu'un pour prouver que c'était bluffant et que ça fonctionnait
Et bien il y a quelques secondes, j'ai fait ce tour là, à Léonard
- Sur ma chaîne
Sur sa chaîne
Donc avant de vous l'expliquer, j'aimerais que vous viviez le moment en faite,
Quittez ma vidéo, vraiment, cliquez sur Léonard
ou cliquez sinon sur la petite fiche au dessus de Léonard
et allez voir la vidéo, allez voir le tour tel que je lui fais.
Comme ça, vous aurez peut-être des débuts d'idées
Et vous revenez ici, vous reprenez la vidéo là
Je vais faire un clap ce sera plus facile à retrouver pour vous
Du coup, tu vas découvrir les explications en même temps
- Allez, exactement, j'ai hâte des les découvrir tu sais
Ah, ben oui, tu m'étonnes, tu viens juste de le vivre !
Toi tu as du bol en faite , tu viens juste d'être bluffé et juste derrière tu as l'explication
- Exactement, ah franchement, quand un magicien te fait un tour
t'as toujours envie de connaître les explications derrière
Explication : 1 ère !
J'avais donc une prédiction que j'avais agrafé qui était ici,
J'aurai pu ne pas l'agrafer, on s'en fiche
Et j'avais un jeu de cartes
Le jeu de carte en fait, c'est un forçage.
Mais je l'ai un peu déguisé
A la fin, il fallait absolument que t'aies le 4 de pique et le 2 de coeur
Ces deux cartes-là
Je les ai mises toutes les deux sur le dessus du jeu
Je t'ai demandé de choisir un nombre, n'importe lequel
Tu as dis 4
- Ouais j'ai dit 4
On aurait pu dire n'importe quoi
Je vous les mets en l'air comme ça vous allez suivre le trajet qu'elles font
Si tu m'avais dit 11, tu vois, qui est un nombre impair ce coup-ci
Ca aurait fait : 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11 !
Ok la personne donc, elle donne les cartes autant que le nombre auquel elle a pensé
Et après, je t'ai dis, "Tu divises tu fais gauche-droite-gauche-droite"
Donc quoi qu'il arrive....les deux dernières cartes que tu donneras...
C'était les deux qui étaient sur le dessus du paquet au tout départ
en fait elles sont descendues, et elles sont remontées
- Et l'explication pour laquelle je choisis ?
Ah oui, donc ça c'est une deuxième partie
Alors je vais vous dire quelque chose
Le tour il est safe à 100%, c'est plus de la magie que du mentalisme là,
quoi qu'il arrive, je vais réussir
mais ça peut être un très bon entraînement pour vous
pour vous entraîner à forcer une carte psychologiquement
Via les autres vidéos que je vous ai déjà expliquées
Si je veux m'entraîner à forcer une dame de coeur avec des mots, avec un discours spécifique par exemple
J'aurai pu mettre la dame de coeur ici,
J'essaie de te la forcer psychologiquement
Et si je rate de toute manière, j'ai la suite du tour qui va faire que quoi qu'il arrive, ça va fonctionner.
- D'accord
Une espèce de filet de secours en fait
Le filet de secours c'est ce petit papier de bristol que j'ai fait ce matin
et sur lequel, vous vous souvenez, tu avais choisi le 4 de pique hein je crois
- Oui, c'est ça
Et sur lequel y'avait marqué effictivement : 4 de pique
En faite y'a marqué 4 de pique ici mais y'a marqué également : 2 de coeur ici
- Ahhh ouais.... obligatoirement ouais... qu'on choisisse  l'une ou l'autre
- 2 de coeur et 4 de pique
Donc en fait, suivant comment je déplis
ça je vous le fait voir hein, j'ai juste plier la feuille en 4 au départ
J'ai fait le point d'interrogation, j'ai marqué 2 de coeur là
Et après je me suis dit "Comment je peux le déplier sans qu'il ne le voit"
Donc j'ai déplié comme ça, comme ça
Et j'ai marqué 4 de pique ici
Comme il n'y a que 2 solutions, c'était facile d'en cacher une
- Ouais, donc dans tous les cas enfaite... t'aurais eu la bonne réponse
- Exactement
- Donc pour te bluffer toi ou pour vous quand vous allez bluffer les gens à qui vous allez le faire
Quoi qu'il arrive, y'avait la bonne solution
Donc je vous disais, si par contre vous voulez en profiter pour vous entraîner à faire un vrai forçage psychologique
Ca vous permet d'avoir un filet de secours si vous vous raté... ça c'est plutôt cool.
- Ouais, c'est cool. Mais du coup, si t'aurais voulu faire un forçage psychologique, tu t'y serais pris comment ?
Alors, j'aurai pas forcément choisi ces cartes-là qui sont assez proches l'une de l'autre
C'est deux cartes faibles où il n'y a pas beaucoup de couleurs, y'a juste le rouge et le noir
Par exemple, j'aurai pris un 3, spontanément au compte de 3 tu vas en choisir une
donc c'est quand tu veux, tu prends celle que tu veux peut-être les rouges qui sont plus dans le coeur
ou peut-être les noirs qui correspondent à des personnalités plus fermes et plus assumées
"Clac' Clac' Clac' " Vas-y
Et tu vois, j'aurai placé comme ça "3" plein de fois
J'aurai placé une valeur sur le noir
- Et t'façon même si j'avais pas choisi le 3, bah t'avais le papier de secours
- Exactement
- Ok ouais, ça peut être une bonne idée pour s'entrainer
Ca va t'as tout compris ?
Ouais, là j'ai tout compris, et j'espère que vous aussi ?
Ah ouais, du coup si Leonard a compris, c'est votre délégué de classe aujourd'hui Leonard en fait
- Exactement
J'espère que cette vidéo ensemble vous a plu,
j'espère que vous êtes allez voir la vidéo de Leonard et surtout
que vous en avez profité pour vous abonner
Regardez une de mes vidéos préférées de toi, c'est : 2010 Vs 2016
Si vous ne l'avez pas vu, regardez-là
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette explication du dimanche
Bluffez les gens à votre tour !
N'hésitez pas à nous laisser un petit commentaire, je les regarde tous
Et je suis sûr qu'il va y jeter un oeil Leonard
- Et surtout un petit "Pouce en l'air !"
Pouce en l'air ! J'ai pas eu le temps de le faire, il a mentalisé mon pouce !
Oui, laissez nous un pouce en l'air
Et avant de partir n'oubliez pas de vous abonnez à la chaîne
puisque le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an !
Un an mec !....Et après je prend des vacances
- Bonne chance
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h,
Tchao !